[موسيقى]
انا متطوع مع ام في مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
بتشتغل في قسم الميديكال سبلايز اللي هو
المهام الطبيه يعني عشان الحرب قعدت وقت
نصحى الصبح على طلبيات ولما نيجي ننام
طلبيات فيش ل نوم ولا ولا شي لا نوم ولا
راحه ولا قاعده ولا شي ما بتلحق تقعد خمس
دقائق اللي تلاقي طلبيه فوق راسك فيش راحه
الاجسام بتطلب طلبيات واحن بصرفها وبنودها
يزن عمره 13 سنه انا بتعامل حاليا مع يزن
على انه عمره 30 سنه ليش لانه كبر قبل
اوانه تحمل مسؤوليه وطن مسؤوليه شعب كامل
يقف في وسط الميدان معرض روحه للخطر
استوعب المسائل و يعني في نفس الوقت خفف
عني كثير يعني رغم صغر عمره لكن يعني يد
بيد انا حاسه اني انا بتعامل مع موظف رسمي
صعبه جدا الظروف بطلت غزه على حالها قبل
ما ضلش حدا في البلد الناس بتتقطع وبتترمى
الناس تحت الانقاض مش قادرين نصل
[موسيقى]
لها المناظر صعبه
جدا
m